transmission to make sure that they get
passed onwards if this was to happen in
the malaria system it might make sense
that it would be something to do with
order that they manipulate because order
is the key or does the thing that links
us between mosquitoes that's how they
find us this is what we call the malaria
manipulation hypothesis and it's
something that we've been working on
over the last few years so one of the
first things that we wanted to do in our
study was to find out whether an
infection with malaria actually makes
you more attractive to mosquitoes or not
so in Kenya with our colleagues we
designed an experiment where we had
participants children in Kenya sleep
inside tents the order from the tent was
blown to a chamber which contained
mosquitoes and the mosquitoes would
behaviorally respond they would fly
towards or fly away from the orders
depending on whether they liked them or
not
now some of the participants were
infected with malaria and some of them
were uninfected but importantly none of
the children had any symptoms whatsoever
now when we find and saw the results it
was really quite staggering people who
were infected with malaria were
significantly more attractive than
people who were uninfected so let me
explain this graph we have a number of
mosquitoes attracted to the child and we
have two sets of data before treatment
and after treatment on the far left hand
side that bar represents a group of
people who are uninfected and as we move
towards the right hand side these people
have become infected and they're moving
towards the stage that they're
infectious so right at the stage when
people are infectious it's when they are
significantly more attractive in this
study then what we did is we obviously
gave the children treatment to clear the
parasites and then we tested them again
and what we find was that highly
attractive trait that was there
disappeared after they had cleared the
infection so it wasn't just that the
people were more attractive it was that
the parasite was manipulating its host
in some way to make it more attractive
to mosquitoes standing out like a beacon
to attract more mosquitoes so that it
could continue its life cycle the next
thing we wanted to do was find out what
it was the mosquito was actually
smelling what was it detecting so to do
that we had to collect the body order
from the participants and we did this by
wrapping bags around their feet which
allowed us to collect the volatile
orders from their feet and feats really
important to mosquitoes they really love
the smell of feet especially cheesy feet
anybody got cheesy feet right there
mosquitoes love that smell so we focused
on the feet and we collected the body
order now when it comes to mosquitoes
and olfaction their sense of smell it's
very complex it would be really nice if
there was just one chemical that they
detected but it's not that simple they
have to detect a number of chemicals in
the right concentration the right ratios
the right combinations of chemicals so
you can sort of think about it like a
musical composition so you know if you
get they're not wrong or you play it too
loud or too soft it doesn't sound right
or a recipe if you get an ingredient
wrong or you cook it too long or too
little it doesn't taste right or smell
is the same it's made up of a suite of
chemicals in the right combination
now our machines in the lab are not
particularly good at picking out this
sort of signal it's quite complex but
animals can and what we do in my
laboratory is we connect micro
electrodes to the antenna of a mosquito
imagine how fiddly that is but what we
also do is connect them to individual
cells within the antenna which is
incredibly definitely not want to sneeze
when you're doing this experiment that's
for sure but what this does is it allows
us to measure the electrical response of
the smell receptors in the antennae and
so that we can see what a mosquito is
smelling so I'm going to show you what
this looks like here's an insect cell
and it's responding it will respond in a
second when I press this button and
you'll see it sort of ticking over with
this response and order will be blown
over the cell and it will sort of go a
bit crazy it'll sort of blow raspberry
and then it will go back to its resting
potential when we stop the order
okay there we go so you can go home now
and say that you've now seen that an
insect smelling and even hearing an
insect smell it's a weird concept isn't
it but this works really well and this
allows us to see what the insect is
detecting now using this method with our
malaria samples we were able to find out
what the mosquito was detecting and we
find the malaria associated compounds
mainly aldehydes a group of compounds
that smelled that signified the malaria
a signal here so now we know what the
smell of malaria is and we've used the
mosquito as a bio sensor to tell us what
the smell of malaria actually is now I'd
like to imagine that you could I don't
know put a harness on a little mosquito
and you know put it on a lead and take
it out and see if we can sniff so if
people in a community that goes on in my
head and see whether we could actually
find people with malaria but of course
that's not really possible but there is
an animal that we can do that with no
dogs have an incredible sense of smell
but there's something a little bit more
special about them they have an ability
to learn and most of you will be
familiar with this concept at airports
where dogs will go down a line and sniff
out your luggage or yourself for drugs
and explosives or even food as well so
we wanted to know could we actually
train dogs to learn the smell of malaria
and so we've been working with a charity
called medical detection dogs to see
whether we can train them to learn the
smell of malaria and we went out to the
Gambia and did some more order
collection on children that were
infected and uninfected but this time we
collected their order by making them
wear socks nylon stockings to collect
their body order and we brought them
back to the UK and then we handed them
to this charity to run the experiment
now I could show you a graph and tell
you about how that experiment works but
that'd be a bit dull would let now they
do say never work with children or
animals live but we're going to break
that rule today so please welcome on
the stage freya and her trainer Mark and
Sarah of course this is the real star of
the show
okay so now what I'm gonna ask is if you
can all just be just a little bit quiet
and don't move around too much this is a
very very strange environment for Freya
she's having a good look at you guys now
so let's stay as calm as possible that
would be great so what we're going to do
here is basically we're going to ask
Freya to move down this line of
contraptions here and in each one of
these contraptions we have a pot and in
the part is a sock that's been worn by a
child in The Gambia now three of the
socks had been worn by children who were
uninfected and just one of the socks was
worn by a child who was infected with
malaria so just as you would see an
airport imagine these were people and
the dog is going to go down and have a
good sniff and let's see if you can see
when she senses the malaria and if she
senses than there's there's a really
tough test for her in this very strange
environment so I'm going to hand over
now to mark
the first three okay there we go
I didn't know which pot that was in mark
didn't know which products and this was
a blind test genuinely Sarah was that
correct that was correct well done Freya
that is fantastic that is really
wonderful okay so that's brilliant know
what we're going to do is Sarah is going
to actually change the pots around a
little bit and she's going to take the
one with malaria away and we're just
going to have four pots that are
containing socks from children that had
no malaria so in theory fear should go
down the line and and not stop at all
and this is really important because we
also need to know people who are not
infected she needs to be able to do that
correctly as well and this is a really
tough test these socks have been in the
freezer for a couple of years now
and and this is a tiny bit of a shock as
well so imagine if this was a whole
person and they were giving off a big
signal so this is really quite
incredible okay over to you Mike
brilliant fantastic really super thank
you so much guys big round of applause
for Freya mark and Sara well done guys
what a good girl she's gonna get a treat
later fantastic so you've just seen that
for your own eyes that was a real live
demonstration I was quite nervous about
it I'm so glad that it worked but it is
really incredible and when we do this
what we find is that these dogs can
correctly tell us when somebody is
infected with malaria 81% of the time
it's incredible 92% of the time they can
tell us correctly when somebody does not
have an infection and those numbers are
actually above the criteria set by the
World Health Organization for a
diagnostic so we really are looking at
deploying dogs in countries and
particularly at ports of entry to detect
people who have malaria this could be a
reality but we can't deploy dogs
everywhere and so what we're also
looking to do and working on at the
moment is the development of technology
wearable tech that would empower the
individual to allow them to
self-diagnose imagine a patch that you
wear on the skin that we detect in your
sweat when you're infected with malaria
and change color or something a little
bit more technical perhaps a SmartWatch
that would alert you when you're
infected with malaria and if we can do
this digitally and we can collect data
imagine the amount of data that we can
collect on a global scale this could
completely revolutionize the way that we
track the spread of diseases the way
that we target our control efforts and
respond to disease outbreaks ultimately
helping to lead to the eradication of
malaria and even beyond malaria for
other diseases that we already know have
a smell if we can harness the power of
nature to find out what those smells are
we could do this and make this a reality
now as scientists
we're tasked with coming up with new
ideas new concepts new technologies to
tackle some of the world's greatest
problems but what never ceases to amaze
me is that often nature has already done
this for us and the answer is right
under our nose thank you
you